March 10 was bonus day for the 8 000
employees of Silicon Valley Bank they
got their bonus that Friday hours later
the bank failed on Monday customers
could be seen lining up to try to
retrieve their funds
Silicon Valley Bank was the bank of
choice for thousands of companies in the
tech sector many of them startups fueled
by Angel Investors almost half of all
the Venture Capital funding in the
United States flowed through the bank at
one time or another and then suddenly it
all came to an end the speed at which
things unraveled caught many by surprise
even the bank's CEO a few weeks before
the collapse CEO Greg Becker told CNBC
that the future looked good what we are
expecting to see in 23 first half
actually even Venture Capital actually a
little bit more of a decline even than
what we saw in the fourth quarter but
the second half was going to kind of
create that that modest Improvement and
really set the stage for a better better
24. so so we're we're optimistic because
our crystal ball is a little clearer
than it was in the third quarter last
year perhaps his crystal ball wasn't
shiny enough to predict the future
startups struggled to raise additional
Venture Capital due to the current
economic environment
so they begin with drawing more and more
of their cash from their svb accounts
the bank had the money in theory but it
wasn't sitting in a vault waiting to be
handed back to its customers you're
thinking of this place all wrong as if I
had the money back on a safe
the bank had invested the money in
treasury bonds a type of government debt
in which the government borrows money
and pays it back with interest when
customers started pulling their money
out of the bank svb had no choice but to
start selling the bonds at a discount so
they could get enough cash to satisfy
customer demand
Becker decided to publicly announce that
the bank had sold off 21 billion in
bonds but those bonds weren't worth as
much as they used to be because the FED
kept raising interest rates when
interest rates go up bond prices usually
go down this is because new bonds have
higher interest rates so people prefer
them over older bonds think of it like
this imagine if you have a candy store
and sell a candy for one dollar this
candy gives the buyer a little 10 cent
surprise each year if another store
sells a similar candy for the same price
but offers a 15 cent surprise each year
people would choose to buy candy from
the other store instead
so the bank had to sell its older bonds
at lower prices which ultimately led to
a loss of 1.8 billion while Becker hoped
to raise more than that in New Capital
he said he had still not found anyone
willing to help the bank ride out the
store
perhaps he was looking to be transparent
but it backfired big time CNN quotes an
anonymous Bank employee as saying that
was absolutely idiotic their
transparency and forthrightness did them
it the extent of the bank's financial
troubles panicked customers leading to a
phenomenon called A Bank Run where
everyone starts taking their money out
of the bank all at once the next day
customers withdrew 42 billion from their
accounts leaving svb with a negative
cash balance of 958 million and public
filings show Becker himself cashed out
personal shares and options worth two
million dollars just before the collapse
the day the bank failed Becker told
employees I'm not making the decisions
anymore
this is the second largest bank failure
in U.S history behind only the collapse
of Washington Mutual at the height of
the subprime mortgage crisis in 2008 and
then the third largest bank failure in
U.S history happened on svb's Heels two
days later on March 12 Regulators shut
down Signature Bank in New York to
prevent the crisis from spreading
through the entire Financial system a
quarter of signature bank's deposits
came from the cryptocurrency sector
but Regulators denied it closed the bank
because of its large hand in crypto and
rather cited what it called a
significant crisis of confidence in the
bank's leadership the question now is
are there more bank failures to come
they are more common than people think
few people are old enough to remember
the
2293 banks that collapsed in 1931. a
development that led to the Great
Depression but there have been more than
500 since the collapse of Washington
Mutual in 2008 although most pale in
comparison to the size of svbs Mark
Williams a former bank examiner for the
Federal Reserve told Boston University's
Daily News website bu today if not
quelled Bank runs can spread like
wildfire crippling even the soundest of
banks to quell further Panic President
Biden quickly assured Americans
Americans can have confidence that the
banking system is safe
your deposits will be there when you
need them in the U.S deposits in a bank
are insured by the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation or FDIC up to 250
thousand dollars however over 90 percent
of deposits at svb exceeded that amount
the federal government then jumped in to
guarantee deposits greater than two
hundred fifty thousand and the Federal
Reserve also said it would make
additional emergency funds available to
eligible financial institutions to
prevent similar problems in the future
billionaire hedge fund investor Bill
Ackman made a point of saying had U.S
Regulators not intervene today we would
have had a 1930s Bank Run continuing
first thing Monday causing enormous
economic damage and hardship to Millions
however Ackman also warned more banks
will likely fail despite the
intervention
there's little doubt that the FED is
partly to blame for svb's stunning
collapse over the past year the Federal
Reserve has been aggressively hiking
interest rates to tame inflation by
making borrowing more expensive which
slows down spending and keeps prices
from rising too quickly and in the
process svb got caught in the undertow
former U.S treasury secretary Larry
Summers criticized regulators and also
the bank's management I have to say that
it doesn't appear on current facts that
a very good job was done of regulating
and supervising uh Silicon Valley uh
Bank it had committed kind of one of the
most Elementary errors of borrowing
money in a very short-term way and then
investing it in a long-term way and then
when interest rates went up those assets
lost their value
some are blaming wokeness for the bank's
demise implying that the collapse was
related to the company's focus on
diversity and inclusion a Wall Street
Journal opinion columnist wrote I'm not
seeing 12 white men would have avoided
this mess but the company may have been
distracted by diversity demands the best
outcome for the failed bank is for U.S
officials to find a buyer there will be
no bailout which typically uses taxpayer
dollars to keep the company afloat Biden
does not want to reignite the anger from
the 2008 Wall Street bailouts that were
funded by taxpayers especially with the
presidential election approaching the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank brings
up memories of another president who
took office in 1933 when Banks were
going under almost daily during his
inaugural address President Franklin D
Roosevelt famously urged people not to
panic let me assist my family
that the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself
nameless unreasoning unjustified Terror
which paralyzes needed effort to convert
Retreat into Advance it appears that 90
years later Roosevelt's wise Council has
been largely ignored
the financial stocks have now lost to
combine 465 billion in just one weekend
but will it be the last disaster this
crash was caused in part by the FED
raising interest rates which they may
still be committed to JP Morgan says the
S P 500 could sink another 20 percent as
the economy is pushed to the brink so
big institutions like them are going big
into alternative assets one alternative
asset Rose an average of 29 last year
handily beating stocks Fine Art
Masterworks offers fully investable art
from Legends like Picasso which are
qualified with the SEC and broken into
shares so you don't need millions of
dollars to invest in fact each of
Masterworks 11 exits to date has
returned a profit as a result paintings
have sold out in hours not days but
right now you can get Priority Access to
skip the wait list with the link in my
description